e mica games mica cazzi proprio bene
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono pavidea di siamo sul lock up
ragazzi non ho la minima idea se devo
essere sincero di che cosa sto per
giocare perché sei ore è un thriller
psicologico che prende
il luogo in un non posso chiuso deve
interagire con le cose che ti circondano
per muoverti attraverso la trama sembra
e la stessa grafica magari c'aveva siren
ed c'è una polaroid bellissima grazie a
noi ci siamo incastrati qua con la
macchina settembre nel 1980 ma devi per
forza muoverti con la lentezza di un
dromedario cioè non capello giorno
piacere giovanni cane va beh va beh mi
senta non si fanno se cose quali video
farvi prendi per cortesia tanto hanno
messo a rumore dei passi brevi giro c'è
un impiccato bene cazzulini kick ass
sfide rino scegliere ma le pagine lowes
lander man o amica che ricordi mamma e
marta va bene grazie avermi fatto vedere
sta cosa era erano miei quei pass non
capisco se chiuso la porta chi è che ha
chiuso la porta ma devo trovare le prime
tre uno slider many miniatura trovo le
pagine in un metro quadro va bene dei
suoi in to happen to you
questa cosa sta per succedere a te c'è
un qualcuno che sta tagliando con sega
un tizio va bene con la videocamera e
youtuber merda salve lei non è che a una
sega perché io sono uno youtuber e
questo potrebbe essere un problema visto
che c'è spingere una cosa lì che non
scusi mi scusi io non avrei guardato la
sedia visto che c'è una tizia lì però
giriamoci verso la tizia che non c'è più
ovviamente visto che guardo le sedie
se c'è una tizia qualche pista allo
specchio ed è
ed è un fantasma non si guardano le
sedici ragazzi [ __ ] a tu madre ma
chi è che smarrito nelle orecchie va beh
comunque noi il gioco è bello quando
dura poco e io vorrei riuscire anche ad
asta casa però è sentite non è che se vi
mettete in posizione di power rangers
fate meno pa una donna di dio
a regà una doccia usatela ogni tanto le
e quelli chi pensa che quelli che non
devono anche notati l'amiamo canale o
questa bella parte
diciassette anni dopo chissà che minchia
è successo nel frattempo vabbè sono in
un dove cazzo son partito che la porta è
chiusa e sono in una stanza che non so
come subito che è tutto sbagliato quello
che sto vedendo come può esserci una
porta chiusa
se sono solo io qua dentro ed è
minuscola stanza come questo finito qua
beresford rap e quindi c'è un simbolo
strano che sembra un tizio incassato
colgono sopracciglio se ci fate caso va
beh a parte quello tutto chiuso il resto
niente abbiamo solo il la porta che non
si apre un 1 eccolo qua c'è sempre il
pizzo incassato nemmeno sopracciglio e
la porta si è aperta non si è aperta la
porta
questo non c'è la prendo comunque mi
giro succedono cose bellissimo aspetta
flashlight cannes a camera c'è anche
mido mouse
ok focus locke camera c
ma niente colaci però anche con la v
anche con la effe non c'è un cazzo nella
camera nella flashlight sugli scatti
disco unboxing fa vj attenzione e va beh
questo vojak incase tappeti imperiale
del sultano perche il bellissimo fare da
eco what fa xvi c'è però posso usarla
camera non c'e lo meno che non vi
diavolo una polaroid mi sono pagato
rivalutandone adesso non è successo
niente
minchia schiacciato il gran giorno
no no no no no eh e vedi che ha buttato
sui quadri cazzi vostri
beh io li prenderei la pistola
la pistola già che ci siamo usiamola
cioè nega la tenera sedativo mischia e
macabra come faccenda però la porta
rimane chiusa ma t bill matilda kate
grace nilmar march anno marciano e un
nome marciume dire marzo effettivamente
ok
io baba bene mi fa piacere ragazzi io
però uscire lo stesso visto che qua
dentro si è presentata e satana nelle
vesti di una signora un po alta quindi
il confronto lady dimitrescu era era
bella infatti era bella ma molto bello
vediamo se riesco a piazzarci le croci
su quelle mancanti tra le due croci
come vedo ci sono due croci ma tre croci
mancanti questo rumore mi succede
e come se qualcuno forzasse cassetti
raga per favor favore te lo chiedo
dichiarazioni dell'agente io ho capito
bene gol però sicuro fanno i miracoli
va bene e non ringraziare però non sono
stato qua dentro ma è buio come la merda
ok ok ok perdendo quindi io io io
rimango fuoco nello sgabuzzino forever
evochiamo saltare insieme va che
allegria sono in balia del di satana lo
sapevo per a meno ma guarda è un sospiro
di sollievo rispetto a quest anno prima
sono contento pensione
si sta appiattendo sempre si sta
stringendo sempre di più o sono io che
no è un effetto ottico effettivamente
però non capì la smettiamo di spegnere
giorno giorno insaccati porca [ __ ]
liscio anche con c'è c'è anche un
canguro luc kat sguardo per terra in
aria
c'è un orsacchiotto [ __ ] assurda
c'è un sacco per cadaveri
la cosa più bella che ho visto in questa
stanza pensate il resto non è
che faccio
ottimo a rimbalzare nella stanza finchè
non mi fai uscire se due porta dietro ne
va avanti
credo che non si apre a nessuna delle
due e invece si è aperta ma mai pensare
in negativo iq di tiri più lista porta
di merda o perfetto non ho ben capito eh
vabbè ma stai cad cam casa si chiama di
gamma di via via via fuori dalle palle
adesso si gira la croce al contrario non
si è girato ok l'altro no va bene mi
aspettavo il si girasse la croce è
contrario non è successo vado di qua
anche se non so che cosa ci sono in
mezzo
devo prendere la torcia prima di
andarmene si dov'è la torcia esattamente
una torcia nei cassetti
la torcia dove minchia l'hai vista zio
non c'è nessuna torcia qua
dovrei prendere la torcia prima delle
via non ci sono torce a era qua dentro
perché però prima di attivarla dovevo
guardare il la polaroid che mi diceva
che c'erano le torce adesso è sparita
tra l'altro ma chi è roba è
io devo guardare gli oggetti sono nomi
si sbloccano le cose cioè pensate che
che malattia bottiglie vabbè comunque la
trama ragazzina dovete spiegare perché
non ha ancora capito che c'è gente che
se che voleva vivere in casa ci sono
quadri la madonna
c'è gente che bussa che ride ci sono
sacche di cadaveri bacon con bellocchio
e allegro e family friends che la se
monetizzato c'è la zia che piange però
non la vedo e questo fosse spuntato
adesso
daywear 6 ma io non ne sarei così
convinto e questa cosa non sarei così
secondo me no
se vuoi un mio modesto parere no però
però andiamo nell'altra stanza che
almeno qualcuno sta illuminando
perlomeno da vedere la socia bene e
allora andatevene affanculo io
ripropongo sempre il bene che se vedi
che lo ciao ragione lo previte di un'ora
si è veramente storto il coso le era
abbastanza prevedibile processo candele
anche per terra la destra tensione hanno
assassinato il cangurino peccato o
sandri
meno male sei entrata avrebbe appunto
avanti tanto siamo già in due qua fa
c'entra il signore no perché ho spento
perché si è aspettato lo spinoso spenta
io vi giuro si aspetta la sola
porca vacca finalmente avrò compagnia
che palle siamo quella solida adatta
sempre almeno non compagnia stavolta
niente né anno si riesce a star
tranquilli cotè preferisco morire da
satana che farà avanti indietro
stavo scherzando e sto scherzando uno
scherzoso che non prendere tutta la
lettera di quello che dico lo prendono
lettera le cose scherzavo tranquillanti
prendo il qualche angolino lo prendo mi
metto sulla stella sul cerchio alchemico
annunciate ok jade e jayden desse in sé
non so niente di quello che ho letto non
puoi andartene niente siamo qua grazie
c'è scritto sotto consentito soprano
leggero
adesso avanti tanto pulisci tu poi
quando tiravo le manate alle porte e mia
mamma mi dice no matter evitate farmar
bach
che differenza fa mancare la polaroid
attaccata un casino raga un casino se
sta roba qua
non ho capito ma va bene porca [ __ ]
cane non è successo niente non è
successo non è successo niente
era esattamente quella roba che vedeva
un e la polaroid benissimo acquista il
bagno signori dopo due ore siamo
riusciti aggiungere il bagno questi sono
traguardi è perché voi poi uno dice eh
ma se youtube air non sanno far cavolo
la pila per la batteria della torcia
tutto chiaro
minchia due ore ho trovato la e non
avevo capito che si bisognasse prendere
la pila ex schiappa gela in the torch o
non mi faccio domande perché tanto non
capire niente quindi è meglio che
continua così bello sto bagno allegro
key to the job
la chiave del cassetto va bene tutto
trova chiami apri cose salve io apro
questo cassetto qui è anzi no dovrei
aprire quello dove andata lei mi scusi è
che qua c'è un cassetto ad aprire questo
qua per la precisione tanto ed io
portavo dalla sedia
mica gaza non siamo a pro cassetta o
perché senza applica sotto trovate le
chiavi
prendi lebron o cristo
madonna di dio regalava che gioco è ma
che gioco è mica una donna ma basta e da
una via è da una vita che non giocava la
roba così è ragazzi cioè minchia che che
anzi ho mica devi stare calmo ketarin
alla cinquina che porca [ __ ] faccio
pure tombolato allora vedi calmarti da
radio pure la smettiamo di mettere
musichette robe per l'amor di dio
e la madonna ma scusa mi chiamo
probabile la porta sì sì sì quello che
dici tu salve non chiude la porta per
favore voglio venire a divertirmi
signori questa era la prima parte del
video di locked up che è chiuso sopra
molto krypi non so se avete notato
c'è chi è scaltro avrà notato che è un
gioco un po krypi però bello bello
divertente speriamo di fare un altro
video se vi è piaciuto lasciato commento
mi piace ragazzi e ditemi se volete che
io continui a me piaciuto parecchio e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]